[Laughter]
should we wait for some people to come
on right now yeah we've got 38 so far
that's cool we'll let you guys uh hang
out in the
hangout area
before we start with the announcements
but i'm very excited about the stuff
we're going to talk about today i think
everyone's going to like it too yes it's
a real
the people are winning it's exciting
it's the people's release yeah you
really did
really went for what people wanted
part strap is also a very people's thing
exactly it's in the description so
people can kind of guess but
all right make sure you guys yeah with
the portrait let's talk about it so just
out now
what are you gonna do here i'll go to
the shop
oh i'm gonna go to shop first yeah
check it out if you scroll all the way
down
new parts all right let's get some parts
wow look at that oh my god
look at this
you can assemble a full comma three with
all these parts don't you guys just hate
it when things break on your electronics
and you can't get replacement parts
well not a problem anymore for the comma
3.
yeah so every component is there and
like for example when you buy the
cameras you get the screws to attach the
camera to the logic board
you buy the heatsink you get the screws
to attach it the only things like we
don't include is the thermal paste so
you know buy your own and then there's
also these parts we don't sell down here
that i conveniently linked uh just the
wi-fi antennas and your own ssd but
other than that
you can build a comma three just from
all this stuff alone which is really
exciting
yeah i'm super excited about this i mean
if you throw your comma three at a rock
and uh the screen breaks don't worry you
could just buy another screen you don't
have to uh you have to buy a new comma
three if i was a user i'm very excited
about this yeah look it goes right to
the digi key place where you get the
antenna pretty cool if you can buy it
from somewhere else i'll just give you
the link
how nice this is so generous
yeah this is super generous so you know
even if a comma 3 goes out of warranty
and like i don't know you drop it in a
camera cracks you can just buy that
single camera we sell each camera
separately yeah some right to repair
stuff oh you get to choose which which
camera nice that's pretty cool
cool yeah we're very excited about this
um
yeah if you break your screen like you
know that's not carved on under warranty
traditionally because you you dropped it
so in that case just uh go buy a new
screen
now you can really easily
yeah i think
this is a really good one guys i think
yeah
i'd be very excited about this yeah and
you can you know if you wanted to go
down that rabbit hole buy every part and
build a comment for yourself but just
know it'll be a little more expensive
than if you just buy one from us so why
wouldn't you do that
fully assembled
there might be someone out there who
would rather build it themselves but oh
and maybe we should know it yes let's
let's note this disclaimer real quick
yeah so only covered if it's dead on
arrival no warranty on this these parts
i think that's pretty pretty small but
yeah that's pretty normal for
replacement parts
yeah but if you know somehow it parts it
on arrival obviously we'll replace it
other than that
test all the parts before they get sent
out so it'll all be good
yeah you can stop stressing now if
you're worried about like always one
small thing gonna break my entire comma
three at least now you have the
opportunity to you know to some
reasonable extent fix it yourself
i think i'm always very into right to
repair and stuff so i think this kind of
stuff is very exciting i think this fits
in well with open source and i'm
guessing you guys all think the same
thing so yeah i'm pretty happy about
this one
great
wanna talk to indeed
we got some new
hiring things uh that dean wants to talk
about real quick so
oh we can show the
it's not fully decorated yet i mean
there's like one
one or two one comma two there's one old
comma two half comma two
it's pretty funny oh what's this a comma
christmas tree
i have no idea
what is that oh it's a speedometer
and then of course some some comma
ornaments
yeah we're really celebrating christmas
over here
what does that even got for us
all right all right
so i just want to quickly chill for some
job post things we put up over the last
couple days
um maybe we should probably just go to
the screen
all right so we really want to hire a
car interface engineer this was
previously the safety engineer job
posting
um but that doesn't quite capture what
we're looking for um
so basically we're looking for somebody
to join the open pilot team and kind of
own all the the whole car experience and
the car support
so we support i think it's 156 cars
right now that's crazy yeah yeah it's
pretty crazy i think we hit 100 this
time last year so the cars are growing
quite quickly
and this is thanks to like good testing
infrastructure and the tools we've built
but there's still tons of room for
improvement
so basically you'll come here you'll own
the internal fleet and the external
fleet
and kind of
improve the bar for quality and really
build tools for the community to develop
really high quality carports
and then along with that
you also do some safety stuff
like when it's time to expand the safety
model
you'll be kind of thinking through that
and writing all the safety enforcement
code for carports and verifying
cool
so
um i'm sure there's somebody out there
in the community who'd be interested in
this job
um basically a software engineer who
knows some things about cars but you
know of course you can come here and
learn stuff about cars
um there's not
you know if you're if you're a good
software engineer
this should be a good position for you
yeah i think this should be a pretty fun
job
and then we've got
this one just went up a couple hours ago
production engineer
so this person will basically um
kind of be at the intersection between
the open pilot team the hardware team
and you kind of work to make sure that
the reliability of the device is where
we want it to be and you do this through
testing infrastructure procedures
debugging devices that come back root
causing them
so this could either be somebody with
like great software engineer who knows
things about hardware
or you know a great hardware engineer
who knows things about software but
we'll be kind of expected to write
really high quality software this isn't
just a bunch of like weird test scripts
all over the place and you know we run
them this is
pretty high quality testing
infrastructure we're developing
and help us kind of scale production and
do this well um
with super high reliability on the
devices
eric said that's what he currently
is
does
you're a software engineer do you want
to work here
um
yeah yeah yeah it says excellent python
and linux skills and t-plus plus like i
don't know if you're a great software
engineer and you don't know python it's
pretty easy to pick up but yeah
come here and
feel free to reach out
really looking for people to uh kind of
come and own this stuff yeah
like as you can see and we have all
these devices here it would be great if
somebody was
here to uh debunk them more immediately
here is a device yeah
this one is stuck registering
oh this one was fixed but you know wait
a second this should never happen oh
this one has a wild problem this one has
the greg problem oh the greg device yeah
if you could figure out what greg is as
gravity thinks
greg has uh
no greg is not fixed
so that's a first job of the new
production engineer he's fixing greg yes
we're also looking for another open
pilot engineer just generally the open
pilot team
so
if a car engineer or a production
engineer don't sound like uh your kind
of thing we're hiring for open pilot
energy or either san diego or rotterdam
the other two positions are just san
diego yep
so gotta be where all the production
happens
yes
a lot of cars we have a lot of things
yeah we got some great parking now yeah
common prime can reach our parking it's
very exciting that is exciting yeah i
was i was pulling logs today and it just
worked comma connect is is getting a lot
better
um we if we talk about it too much but
come connect really has some cool stuff
you can now like request to upload
certain
uh certain files off your device and
they'll just pull over i mean i saw that
that was pretty cool yeah you just did a
great job with that yeah so connect's
getting better everything's getting
better people's really connected
people's release of for everything
people at least the martial
yeah i think the park shop is a real
people's thing the people's release of
open pilot it's like it's for us too
it's more for us than we do we don't
need to buy parts that we do all right
we will go for a drive in the stream
we'll uh we'll check out all the i think
cool exciting
things uh
i mean i'm very excited about i think we
fixed a lot of things that people were
complaining about that we were
complaining about so i think this is
gonna be a really great release yeah
things that have been annoying for years
are now
finally finally getting some attention
all right let's go for a drive i think
i'll meet you outside chris it's great
sounds good
yeah i'll put it on lte
um
glad to hear everything's going well
with the the new unit
all right i'm just going to show off one
more thing
i think this is pretty cool
uh you know the the software engineers
have a have a christmas tree but we have
a christmas wreath
and we also have
a charlie brown christmas tree
and it plays
plays the music
so uh yeah we're working really hard on
getting all the comma threes out from
the black friday sale uh
so far we haven't even you know passed
any deadlines and we're really ramping
up so for those who are still waiting
definitely if you haven't received a
shipping label yet expect one probably
next week
all right yeah let's go meet harold i'm
gonna go on lte so i'll cut out for a
second
okay
here we go
all right harold
all right
so we gave you guys reasonably priced
repair parts
and now we're going to give you some
software as well
so the first big thing that we've spent
a lot of time working on for this
release
is uh
behavior of the lamest model around
exits
it's been a
frequent complaint that when there are
uh these types of exits that are common
in america where they split um from the
lane without
any dividers
that home pilot sometimes kind of splits
the difference or takes the exit when
maybe you shouldn't have taken the exit
or just kind of swerves a little bit
towards the exit so mitchell has done an
incredible job on this he's been working
on on improving that for quite a long
time
and completely reworked the way we
classify what exits are and how to
behave around them
so we're going to try that today oh
jesus christ
all right
there has to be some live demo issues
here so
that's a one-off
um
it's real live when it's not
pre-recorded
this is uh getting all these streams of
all the negative effects of live demos
but all the uh
none of the disadvantages because you
guys aren't here so you don't even
believe it
anyway that seems to have gone away hear
the new sounds by the way oh yeah
another people's release
thing take a listen
yeah so the first thing is we put a lot
of effort into better exits the other
thing is the sounds um you know the
sounds on the comma 3 didn't sound that
great it's it's very difficult to make
sounds that sound great on
you know
yeah run master
on devices like a comma 3 or a cell
phone like cell phones have good sounds
because they've put an incredible amount
of engineering effort in making those
tiny shitty speakers on the phone sound
relatively good
so yeah this is master by the way this
is how it's going to go to releases in
a12
um yeah so it's like an early look at
812 a12 will be you know coming out
pretty soon
has to go through the whole testing
process
yeah so we're going to start off by
trying some exits here so like i said
mitchell has reworked a lot of how we
classify exits and deal with exits in
lateral control i think this is the
biggest complaint people had about
lateral and so we're going to try that
out make sure that kind of works the way
we um we intended to it should just
drive by almost all exits now without
any weirdness
so i think that's that's something
people really will enjoy
and then the other big thing is sounds
hearing them here
the sounds are they're much more chimey
yeah they're real and they sound really
good on the device they sound amazing
but it makes the common three sound
incredible as we said it would
so that's exciting
it's been a long time coming the sounds
have taken a very long time to perfect
but we're finally there yeah it's
surprisingly difficult to get very good
sounds i mean these sounds have been
designed by a sound engineer
specifically for the common three
specifically for cars also you can saw
this exit i mean is driving
super straight rock steady
i mean this is kind of the experience
we've been having with the this latest
model since mitch has done all this work
on the echo behavior
so i think that complaint
has really improved that time
so let's see here this car is taking the
exit and our car didn't even flinch and
i mean this is just kind of how it and
how it works now so that's a huge
improvement in exit behavior so i really
hope you guys
are gonna be happy with that
yeah it's like it's insane it it's never
even flinched anymore like when i drive
to work every day sometimes it would now
it doesn't even
think about it yeah it's really crazy
how much uh how much that rework that
mitchell did has improved this
this stuff
this is just
a smooth merger
um so yeah those are the so the three
big things are we gave you much better
behavior on exits people have explained
that for a while that was very difficult
to fix you know mitchell spent a lot of
time doing that it was very difficult
it's a very complicated stack on how we
classify exits
and lane changes and stuff and improving
that's very difficult but yeah so
mitchell did a great job with that the
other big thing is sounds
we
have completely new sounds designed by
sound engineer specifically for this
device it's completely different than
what the comma 3 has been sounding like
and for me it's addressed
you know all the complaints i had the
same complaints about the comma 3 sounds
as you guys did i think this completely
does away with that and then the last
big thing another big complaint has been
uh just longitudinal control in general
and more specifically at low speeds and
in stop-and-go traffic
so we've spent all this time over the
last couple years really improving
lateral control in open pilot and
long-term control has never gotten that
much attention
and in the last few releases we've
really cleaned up the api and stuff
and now we're at the point where we can
really start improving the policy so
we've shortened the follow distance to
match better what humans kind of do
and we've made the braking and
acceleration behaviors behind other cars
more natural
so i think that really addresses most of
the issues that people had
let's see here this is going to be a
tough one oh it's going to take this
exit
yeah i mean
there's still some issues is with the
with cases where it's completely
ambiguous and if the leads take the exit
but it should be much much more
confident now in whether it takes the
exit or not the exit i think the worst
behavior is where it does something in
between and that
is i think the biggest concern that's
been been addressed and then if there's
no car generally it
doesn't take the exit and if it looks
very ambiguous and there are cars then
it's kind of more difficult to
tell yeah i might need big model for
that
yeah that'll help once we get there so
yeah and then uh so i think the biggest
two things we've addressed here
completely new set of sounds
specifically for the comma 3
new and improved lateral model with a
big focus on improving the exit behavior
let's get back into the exit lane here
and then the stop and go policy
so
we'll turn around here and then we'll be
able to
go in more stop and go traffic and we
can talk about kind of
the approach we took to improve the
behavior there
yeah i've been driving the accord which
doesn't have a pilot longitudinal and i
like went in the civic for 10 minutes
and i was shocked at how different it
feels than it used to
yeah it's really been changed
so everyone's gonna love it i
file distance is shorter in certain
cases and i think it feels just you know
like harold said a lot more human um
because it's inspired by humans yeah
yeah so i think that the big thing that
has been changed with the new
longitudinal policies i really started
looking into
what the braking maneuvers are that
humans do behind a stopped car or behind
slow moving traffic and compare that to
what open pilot policy was doing and i
could see some different patterns
i think those of you that drive with how
long you will have noticed that it
breaks relatively early for a stopped
car and then starts very slowly creeping
into the car ahead of you and that was
just a function of how
our open pilot longitudinal policy dealt
with a speed difference between a lead
and between you
so what i did is i looked at
what
does the data look like from human
driving and designed a function that
matches that
and so by doing that
we get now stopping behavior that looks
much more natural and much more human so
slow down uh later and it won't do this
weird creeping thing and it will in one
like relatively smooth motion uh come to
a stop i don't know if there's gonna be
a stop card here in front of you if
um but yeah so really looking at kind of
what does human behavior look like what
feels natural and trying to you know
build functions that try to mimic that i
think we managed to get much smoother
with natural feeling control so there's
that and then there's also the follow
distance we've had
you know a long follow distance for a
long time because it adds some buffer
for if it makes other mistakes and we
just haven't had it as a priority to
look into that because there were so
many bigger issues with our longitudinal
policy but most of those have been
addressed
and so now we looked at the data you
know what's the following distance that
humans usually take and what's like a
reasonable buffer on top of that for
open pilot to take and then we
implemented that
so those kind of those changes i think
change uh the whole stop-and-go feeling
of open pilot long-term
completely
yeah
it's incredible you don't realize i
think how how bad it was until you try
the new the new version like for me the
the slow creep
like i didn't even think about it
because i've driven with open pilots for
so long but yeah it really did didn't it
yeah i mean once you start paying
attention to it also feels a lot worse
of course
san diego look how pretty it is you can
come work here
i guess there was one more bug that we
also fixed is that uh
there's a bug in the long tunnel policy
that if you were stopped behind or just
stopped in general you started to try
accelerate then it went through this
like weird state machine that went like
through a starting state and it ended up
just taking a second longer to start
moving than it should have so that's
been fixed i think it's a pretty common
complaint as well that it doesn't
accelerate fast enough from a stop uh so
that's been been helped a lot by that
bug fix and then just the general
changes yeah so already we're in some
traffic to get on the highway
uh let's see how it feels
it's feeling good
yeah we're not uh testing end-to-end
longitudinal today this is regular
longitudinal but that means it's also
gonna release in the next open pilot
version which is exciting and tan's long
game but
yeah stuff's coming out now
yeah we are working on the end-to-end
long tunnel and the big mall and that
stuff is just
you know this this policy is not going
to go away tomorrow or next week or next
release so
we wanted to spend some time trying to
address these big complaints that people
had
so that's why it's the people's release
the people's really really
try to focus uh on some of the issues
that have been annoying people
you guys stop here for the light
if you don't know what n10 longitudinal
has watched our previous streams where
we uh try it especially the last one
when it actually worked
yeah it's been a continual improvement
process
[Music]
yeah we'll go in some traffic here but i
mean yeah you can't really feel i think
most of the things that
have been improved are things that you
kind of just feel and for those of you
who have open pilot longer to know i
think you'll you'll feel a pretty big
difference
the big three things that we worked on
are the sounds
the longitudinal
and better x behavior
the people's release and then departure
but it's also for the people yes
all teams are working on stuff for the
people lately
yeah
christmas time is coming we wanted some
you know some excitement
yeah we're in the civic for those who
are asking by the way
is there anything else that people want
to know about ask questions
you can ask anything about what we just
said about the people's release
about the park shop yeah part shop got
longitudinal
does anyone bought a pipe from the park
shop
all right
who knows maybe it's you know doesn't
hurt to have a spare cam
need one of them collect them all
yeah so i mean i'd say already this is a
shorter
follow distance maybe than it used to
have at least on the civic it's a little
too long for me when i would drive on it
yeah it's about 20 shorter than what it
used to be so
[Music]
it kind of splits the difference between
what
the policy used to be and what humans
seem to be doing it's a little bit
somewhere in between
we all really quite want to go to like
the human follow distance because humans
are a bit more reactive and you know
some chill
you want to have some some time to take
over you don't want to be
on your toes all the time
yeah no no plans to release the
the schematic um
let's see
this is uh
now the civic has it's the knight x
civic so it just has stop and go with
open pilot
it does have a pedal door now i think oh
using the pedal i think so
huh we might be using a pedal maybe
nothing
i'm not entirely sure
i don't think i think we are
it could be wrong i don't know either it
doesn't feel super different to be
honest
with her without the pedal
yeah
let's
see uh leonard drive said
who's the following distance i'm not
really sure i think
because you have a non-open pilot acc
car you set follow distance zone pilot
just says one follow distance which is
pretty conservative so that's been
lowered by 20 depending on the speed
you're going
um
yeah i mean what's the follow distance
it depends right
no it's uh i mean it's in steady state
so if you and the lead car going the
same speed it's 1.45 seconds now and it
used to be 1.8
so it's about 20 shorter
yeah this feels great
yeah i mean those seems to be i feel
like there was traffic here just a
minute ago i'm not quite sure what
happened
but uh i don't know you guys will will
feel it i think this
uh this will make it to release soon and
i really hope that uh
it fixed as many of your guys's
complaint as it did hours
and i think after this kind of revamp of
longitudinal uh there's gonna be a
bigger focus on internet longitudinal
the first thing that i think we can ship
is going to be if you're stopped at the
light and the light turns green
you want to accelerate pretty hard
behind the car in front of you or even
if there's no car you want to accelerate
pretty hard but with the current policy
there's not enough context to allow that
acceleration and not accelerate way too
hard in other situations
so hopefully when you have the model the
mall is going to say like oh here it's
appropriate to accelerate really hard
and then we can allow that level of
acceleration
all right here we go we're getting into
the traffic
yeah
see how it feels for us
yeah i think you know before
before all these changes i didn't always
have open pilot engaged in stop and go i
think there's some cases that just
handled quite poorly and it wasn't
always that comfortable and if we had if
i had passengers sometimes i'd have to
take over because it just felt a little
bit too weird
but i think it's gone now i'm i'm super
comfortable with this new new policy
yeah this is this is awesome
i pretty much always disengage for stop
and go so
big improvement
yeah and uh i mean if anyone has a stalk
acc and wants to get in some of the
action you know
i'm gonna get these cars ported that's
right
okay longitudinal working for your cars
um
yeah i guess ideally you find radar
tracks like the
like greg found
in the hyundais yeah the radar tracks
would be great
thanks for the work looks awesome cool
yeah this feels great
yeah i'm pretty happy with it
so you had to reiterate guys completely
new sounds
uh
just disengage and re-engage let's get a
sense of i mean it's kind of different
than it is in real life yeah let me put
it in front of the speakers
hear that i don't think i can trigger an
alert somehow
but uh
yeah completely new sounds they should
sound great on your
devices
and
completely new longitudinal policy with
a big focus on making stop and go just
way more human-like natural and
comfortable
shorter follow distance
bug fix for
accelerating from stop
and then
taking less exits
yeah
it's fantastic release
so yeah this release is you know going
to come out soon it's going through the
release schedule we'll release a full
blog post as we've now been doing with
all the releases
and uh yeah maybe when it comes out
we'll do another stream to say that it's
out yeah we can do something we can post
some plots kind of show what kind of the
changes how
you know it's very easy to simulate
longitudinal policy because it's one
dimensional so you can do really cool
plots very easy to kind of debug for
lateral this is all kind of more
complicated it's not that easy to
kind of show behavior from from like a
single plot to the long tuning was
pretty easy so
yeah i mean there's a bunch of other
stuff in this release too but the kind
of the big ones
i'm trying to think of
yeah are the new alert uh tech's gonna
get i think it will yeah i think that's
already on this one actually i think a
deep indeed reworked some of the alerts
makes them a bit clearer you know less
confusing text yeah
yeah i mean this release too you know
there's certain alerts that were
you know read before like really
separating uh between immediate
disengage and uh
where like something is wrong with
hardware or something like that versus
um
like if you unbuckle your seatbelt for
example that's a different kind of
disengage so now you can kind of tell
the difference between those two modes
and they have different sounds and
things
so that's nice and you know a lot
there's if there's an alert that didn't
need to be read then it's it's or oh
should we give that a test well you want
to unbuckle your seat belt that's a good
oh that sounds so don't do that i'm
going to low gear
it's still steering uh it still steers i
think yeah so then it disengaged so see
that's a lot more pleasant than
[Music]
because that's happened to me i've
accidentally tapped into neutral and
yeah i know i mean
i would go to like uh electric break or
whatever it is and then just
yell that yeah
but yeah the buck one's probably the
same on the same kind of alert yeah i
can try but i think it's the same thing
these fastened
[Music]
yeah
so as you hear i mean those sounds are a
lot more pleasant too um obviously if
there's a real
you know red alert like bad thing it's
gonna be extremely loud and get your
attention as it should so
it hasn't changed there
yeah i think for some alerts you know it
still makes sense to be very aggressive
yeah
right very important so yeah i mean
this is great it's a great release we
keep finding more things that the user
is going to love yeah i think so
yeah
i don't know i don't know what's what's
next after this i think after this
release is going to be a you know a
bigger push on like
the entrance longitudinal stuff and at
some point we're also going to have to
ship you know remove the laneless toggle
it's always lame this time i think
we're getting there we're getting there
yeah does anyone have any complaints
from lanelist that they want to
use this opportunity to talk about
i think i mean i've been driving online
this for you know forever nabi last if
n10 longitudinal and lateral are two
different models or are they one in the
same there's only one model there's only
ever one model one model does everything
it measures the speed it does
calibration
you know it does the lane line it does
the lane lines it does the end to it
lateral does the antenna longitudinal it
tells you if you're going to disengage
or not tells you you know tells you
everything
there's just
i mean not necessarily any benefit to
having multiple models we used to have
like
one model that did pose nets
and like measure the speed and stuff
and then a separate model that did the
driving but now this is all kind of one
big thing one mod is everything
yeah cool a lot of people keep asking
when is the white camera gonna be used
we're working on it yeah we're working
on it i mean the reason there wasn't a
big push on it before is because we've
tested some basic tests and we didn't
get that much benefit from the white
camera for
a lot of things like there's the issues
are just in other places there's bugs
there are other problems
and we didn't want to you know spend so
much time shipping the white cam and we
were already quite confident that at the
time it wasn't going to improve anything
so
but now for the end-to-end longitudinal
you know you stop at a red light it
turns green it's not going to go because
it doesn't see the green light
so for that we do need the big model so
that's why we're working on it now but
it's you know it's quite a big change so
it takes a bit of time
cool yeah a lot of people saying this
does well some people saying that uh
what are the complaints what are what
are the best the complaints are like
cartoon related the car wobbles so much
with laneless
yeah i'd be happy to look into some of
those if you guys could send some routes
on discord or post some bug reports yeah
we are moving to laneless only so you
know
this isn't this is these are issues that
need to be fixed yeah someone said their
toyota low speed like kind of jerks the
wheel around at lane lists and also
sounds like tuning um
yeah i mean lanes interacts quite
differently with uh you know with
control so it's
it's going to be different uh it's going
to be more sensitive to some things with
tunes and less sensitive to other things
and uh
so those are things that you know we
don't necessarily know about
if you have any particularly bad
experiences with lanes that you feel
like don't happen
with lane lines you know peace
you know you can always complain on
discord i think basically all complaints
like that that have a route at least
look at and it's generally helpful yeah
and it's very easy to to find a route
now or you know find where it happens
you just go to connect.comma.ai
see what happens and uh copy the segment
info it's like a
three dots you click that copy this
segment and you just paste it in that's
how you get the wrap
um
cool
i think that's about it huh
yeah i don't really have much else
people's release coming soon to your
commentary
we're people too and we like this one so
yes this is this is the best really in a
long long time it reminds me of like
when zero eight came out
like zero seven came out these big yeah
releases those were some really good
ones
the zero six series i think didn't fix
like phantom break yeah longitudinally
that was that was a great release
this is up this is up there with the
greats exactly
go down history
cool cool see you guys
bye everyone see you in another stream